I never asked you your name max my name
is max
and Mad Max you begin with nothing
your car your family your life
everything has been taken from you now
all that's left is your will to survive
the first thing you must do is build a
new car here cigars magnum opus this is
your magnum opus acquiring necessary
gear throughout your journey allows you
to upgrade your vehicle
these upgrades will let you build and
customize your magnum opus just the way
you want
in addition you will need to equip
yourself with armor and weapons in order
to stand a chance against your enemies
as you progress you will also need to
upgrade your gear and abilities to
survive against the brutal forces of the
wastelands griffa can help help you
venture down to a add and go yourself
and lay bare your true promise
while ammunition can be exceedingly
scarce there are plenty of other weapons
at your disposal that can prove to be
just as deadly
the wasteland is also filled with
valuable scrap that lets you forge new
weapons upgrade armor and make powerful
improvements to the magnum opus
providing you with the strength to
continue fighting effectively
[Music]
those with resources rule the wasteland
and screwed us in his war boys are the
ones in control
they are merciless lethal and relentless
in their thirst for blood
out here if you want to increase your
chances of survival you can't let
anything stand in your way
you must be ruthless
the wasteland is no place for a
conscience
as you travel through the sprawling open
world you will meet those that have
carved out a meager existence in the
wasteland making alliances with these
inhabitants will help them and their
strongholds thrive and provide you with
additional aid along your journey
I need powder black deadly and smoking
and that's where I come in no no listen
you go get me this and you're set for
ammo for life
you must take on the forces that rule
the wasteland and endure the
unpredictable elements of nature
there are dangerous factions that roam
the roads dwell underground and rule the
night they will try to steal what little
you have left
but you still have what it takes
defeat your enemies and reclaim the life
they store
and we'll survive
because you aren't max
you